chaque semaine vous mettez votre bac de
récupération au chemin et ce qui se
passe après peut paraître un peu
abstrait les québécois envoient chaque
année près d'un million de tonnes de
matières recyclables dans les centres de
tri
rue au centre de tri puis aux
installations de conditionnement ou de
recyclage votre bac fait du chemin
une partie du contenu de votre bac sera
en effet très loin jusqu'ici en inde des
sacs les emballages de plastique de
marque familière
c'est quoi
maintenant plus doux cachemire
deux épaisseurs
mais non
chanteuse là
mélange du randonneur
mélange des bois et ça ça vient de
toronto une fois triés elles sont
acheminées vers les différents marchés
qui leur donneront une seconde vie
est ce qu'on en fait après ne correspond
pas toujours aux promesses des
gouvernements
ligue 1
comment ce plastique récupérées dans les
bacs à recyclage at il aboutit dans ces
terrains vagues à l'autre bout de la
planète pour être brûlés pour le savoir
nous avons remonté toute la chaîne d'un
commerce international encore très
opaque
peu de gens le savaient mais avant 2018
une grande partie de nos déchets à
recycler étaient exportés en chine comme
ceux du reste de la planète en pleine
croissance économique l'appétit de la
chine pour les déchets recyclables
semblait insatiable et ses exigences de
qualité minimes les matières étaient
souvent mal trié au difficilement
recyclables mais il y a quatre ans la
chine a décidé que les coûts sociaux et
environnementaux étaient devenus trop
lourds l'industrie du recyclage est
ancré au québec elle mayer un cyclo d'or
de la sirène elmundo giallorossi bilal à
bassorah d'occident
partout dans le monde le choc est
terrible
les matières s'accumulent les centres de
tri crie à l'aide
aux lèvres et pu recevoir des matières
qui dépend de qualité parce que
oh
devenir la poubelle de brit-brit
pense que deschamps depuis on dit
frustré
notre périple a commencé par une
question notre plastique polluent t-il
toujours les pays plus pauvres continue
ton d'exporter notre problème ailleurs
le début de la chaîne il est ici nos
bacs de recyclage commencent tous leur
route dans un centre de tri pierre avare
présidait jusqu'à tout récemment récup
estrie qui opère le centre à sherbrooke
depuis 2018 beaucoup d'efforts ont été
déployés pour recycler davantage les
matières au pays mais une matière qui
avant partait en chine constitue un
véritable casse tête pour les centres de
tri
l'accumulation des 15 derniers mois des
sacs de placer la plupart des centres de
tri au québec ne savent plus quoi faire
de tous ces sacs et pellicules de
plastique qui en principe doivent être
recyclées et leur chemin semble
s'arrêter ici qu'est ce que vous faites
avec ses sacs lors
en 2019 seulement 3% de ce plastique
souple de peu de valeur étaient recyclés
au canada puis cela bon mais dans les
pins messe dans l'épicerie le plastique
souple comme ça les emballages partout
la wii se sautent marc ollivier a
consacré sa vie au recyclage il est
professeur et chercheur en gestion des
matières résiduelles un sac de lait
québon
ou y regarder il ya le sait gleut donc
de la recyclabilité c'est un problème de
commercialisation parce que la demande
est insuffisant présentement au québec
parce qu'on n'a pas encore développé
suffisamment notre industrie qui reprend
du classique numéro 4 pour faire votre
choix ce qui se passe avec à ce moment
là c'est que tout ce qu'on peut
commercialiser ici en va le faire et les
surplus qu'on n'est pas capable de
commercialiser ici c'est ce qui va des
ballot qui sont vendues à l'étranger
mais ou à l'étranger pour le savoir
bonne chance une fois que les matières
recyclables sont vendus à des courtiers
elle entre dans une filière
internationale où on en perd la trace
notre enquête piétine est ce sont les
découvertes d'un inspecteur belge qui
vont nous lancer dans une toute nouvelle
direction nous allons apprendre que les
déchets de plastique voyage toujours
très loin mais caché sous un autre
emballage le port d'anvers deuxième plus
grand port d'europe
après rotterdam
marque de strooper est inspecteur
environnementale au port d'anvers un
point de transit important pour les
navires de marchandises voyageant entre
l'amérique du nord et l'asie
complet de papier qui fera du canada
nous l'avons contacté parce que dans un
obscur rapport international il a publié
le résultat d'inspection concernant des
conteneurs de papier mixte canadien
c'est la catégorie de papier recyclable
la plus exportée
les cargaisons expédié par quatre
compagnies différentes ont été
interceptés en 2019 et 2020 c'est la
raison pour laquelle il les a stoppés
qui a attiré notre attention elles
étaient contaminés par une grande
quantité d'autres déchets principalement
du plastique deux jours avant notre
arrivée il venait d'intercepter 20
conteneurs de papier provenant du port
de montréal à destination de l'inde il
s'apprête à en ouvrir devant nous il y a
probablement un problème parce que
l'offre j'aime
beaucoup plus bas que
des papiers propre c'est possible il ya
beaucoup de pollution dans le passé
ça pue vraiment
ici à l'europe la qualité beaucoup mieux
et a beaucoup beaucoup de plastique
c'était impossible de résister
avez vous l'impression que ça a été très
vite fait les leurs ils n'auront pas du
tout surtout
il ya tant de choses qui de là dedans
qui qui se pend dormantes ou le papier
que le péché de partie où je vois avec
mes voeux fait cinquante années de
l'expérience c'est un des plus graves
que j'ai que j'ai vu dans toute cette
année pour lui ce sont des déchets
mélangés dont l'exportation est
interdite dans des pays comme l'inde
sans leur consentement préalable ils
doivent retourner au canada
pour voir quelqu'un qui vend ça pour des
papiers normale avec des prix élevés
c'est
vraiment un crime l'inspecteur estime à
environ 25% le taux de contamination de
ces ballots alors que la limite légale
indienne pour cette catégorie de papier
est de 2 % 25 % ça ne vous dit
probablement pas grand chose mais dans
le monde du recyclage c'est énorme la
clé du recyclage c'est le tri plus est
propre et homogène mieux ça se recycle
et se vend c'est sûr que si vous avez 25
% de la masse d'un ballot qui n'est pas
du papier il ya un gie ce sévère
fabrication du bateau pourrait qu'on va
exporter des choses tout croche comme ça
dans les autres pays en un an et 0 iront
avec vous savez un conteneur l'ossalois
pas des fenêtres pour qu'on voit ce qu à
l'intérieur nous avons appris que
l'exportateur des conteneurs est un
courtier basé en italie mais les déchets
eux ont été achetés à montréal au centre
de tri de saint michel
l'un des plus gros du québec le centre
appartient à la compagnie ricco va ricco
va c'est un joueur de taille dans le
secteur du recyclage
au québec la compagnie gère trois
centres de tri dont les deux de la ville
de montréal le canada assez connus comme
pays très belle avec beaucoup de nature
et
des gens qui aiment la nature et
je ne comprends pas qu'ils peuvent
j'étais d'un déchet comme ça qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire avec tout ce qui n'est
pas papier ils vont le jeter là où il
faut brûler en plein air
[Musique]
on n'a vu qu'une grande quantité de
plastique voyage caché dans du papier
dont le commerce international est
beaucoup moins surveillées alors le
suivi ces conteneurs jusqu'à leur
destination en inde dans une région
archi pollué et malheureusement il ya un
peu de nous autres là dedans
[Musique]
las de voir
les bouteilles
les masques
c
comment expliquer que les ballots de
papier montréal est interceptée à anvers
contiennent autant de plastique couleur
caustique toutes sortes de plastiques
on est toujours en train d'améliorer la
façon dont on s'approprie les matières
les rangs les plus propres les plus
intéressants pour qu'ensuite des
acheteurs dewey les ballots qui viennent
de montréal la cdc c'est du moins ceux
du bon matériel
lorsqu'elle a ouvert un nouveau centre
de tri en novembre 2019
la ville de montréal avait pourtant
promis qu'elle produirait des matières
de qualité la responsable de
l'environnement au comité exécutif de la
ville n'a pas voulu regarder devant la
caméra les images tournées au port
d'anvers mais nous la lui avons montré
avant l'entrevue et c'est là que ça
devient compliqué est-ce que ce que vous
avez vu là ça vous semble une bonne
qualité le de matériel à exporter
absolument pas non est ce que je vois là
c'est vraiment très contaminée le sait
moi je teins peu bouche bée
pourtant la ville reçoit chaque mois des
rapports sur la qualité des matières
sortant du centre de tri et les chiffres
qu'elle nous a fourni correspondent à
ceux de l'inspecteur belge les taux de
contamination du papy mixte sortant du
centre de tri de saint michel ont été de
26% en moyenne l'an dernier
point vous êtes surprise les images que
j'ai vues j'avais l'impression que ça
pouvait être plus que 25 pour ça mais je
m'y connais pas mais pour le président
du groupe ricoh va ce problème de
contamination élevée n'existe tout
simplement pas et il remet en question
les méthodes de calcul de la ville nous
autres on peut dire que les clients qui
reçoit so i team dit pour qu'il ya
autant d cantonade comme seul sport je
sais pas comment est ce que a
pourquoi il dit sors et je pense que des
fois la manière ils font des calculs y
aider afin qu il considère comme
contaminé mais spontané ce
chaos
lanka tonglet s'est tout dé a failli que
poté qui vous monte le voleur est ce que
votre méthodologie est bonne tout à fait
ricco va à des nomades a t elle même une
entreprise pour effectuer la
caractérisation d'après les rapports de
recyc québec ce taux de 25 % ça
correspond à la réalité de tous les
centres de tri au québec sauf que les
chiffres cités de recyc québec remonte à
2010 9 soit peu de temps après la crise
provoquée par la chine nous avons appelé
12 centres de tri dont les plus gros
québec et il affirme être bien en
dessous de ce tour en raison des
améliorations apportées depuis chose
certaine la contamination constatée par
l'inspecteur de strooper en belgique est
tellement élevées qu'elles entraîné le
renvoi des conteneurs à montréal
mais dominique colibri aller conteste
aussi les évaluations de l'expert
peut-être connaît pour le même siège
travaux urgents s p 25 ans qui fait ça
mais moi sauf le 37 ans je suis le
recyclage puisque benbouzid en
accaparant du stock j'ai pas de prouver
que c'est normal qu'ils voient toujours
à warren cet indice peut décontaminer
landa c'est l'inde qui est le principal
client de ricoh va comme celui de
nombreuses autres compagnies canadiennes
c'est donc en inde que nous nous sommes
rendus pour voir les impacts concrets
débat l'eau contaminée
[Musique]
nous avons quitté la capitale new delhi
en route vers la ville de fernand gare
l'une des zones où se concentrent les
papetières en inde
en ce début du mois de novembre
la pollution de l'air atteint des
niveaux critiques elle se mêle à la
brume du matin
[Musique]
avant de venir nous avions identifié les
principales du zelda mozafar naggar qui
importe le papier à recycler canadiens
dont celui de ricoh va et localiser les
terrains autour pour hommes et femmes
tout de suite ça nous saute aux yeux
mr en mai par mme
moret véhicule
j'ai passé des fruits on aurait dû la
nourriture pour chat le president's
choice
qu'est-ce qu'on a nord est du bo
on retrouve même notre sac de lait
québon dont nous avions discuté à
l'épicerie avec notre expert en feng et
facilement
l'écrivain
on voit bien les déchets européens et
américains mais c'est le plastique
canadien qui semblent prédominer les
matières nous confirme-t-on viennent une
papetière des environs qui les remet à
des sous traitants pour être triés
vers 9 heures un groupe de femmes
arrivent sur les lieux
moi j'ai hâte à demain
et leur dur travail commence
venez danser
c'est un peu plus de 3 dollar canadien
par jour les trieuses sépare le
plastique mou du plastique rigide qui
lui sera vendue pour être recyclés pour
améliorer leur sort elle espère toujours
trouver des billets étrangers mais ils
sont souvent déchirés
juste à côté un autre terrain où
s'amoncellent encore plus de déchets une
sorte de mine à ciel ouvert d'où l'on
extrait du plastique et ici aussi
beaucoup d'emballages canadien il y a
même des sacs réutilisables deux marques
bien connues dont un sac de recyclage de
la ville de toronto
dans trois autres terrains que nous
visiterons par la suite nous serons
surpris par la grande quantité de
déchets canadien et où va le plastique
mou qui est rejeté et mis de côté
lorsqu'on le demandent aux trieuse elles
disent ne pas le savoir mais ce
travailleur nous révèle qu'une partie du
plastique retourne aux usines
on ne nous en dira pas plus pour le
moment
ces travailleurs sont en bas de
l'échelle de tout un écosystème qui
s'est bâtie autour de l'industrie
papetière
nous à fare naggar compte 30 de ses
usines nous découvrons vite que leur
présence ne fait pas l'unanimité dans
les villages autour
en bonne partie en raison de ce qui
arrive aux plastiques souples importer
les villageois affirment qu'une fois
triés le plastique n'est pas recyclé
loin de là selon eux des papetières en
brûle une partie pour générer de la
chaleur dans leur chaudière
du monde sait que ça vient de l'étranger
ça vient dans les déchets
les gens l'achètent pour presque rien
ou deux roupies par kilo
s'ils utilisaient du bois ça leur
coûterait de 20 à 30 roupies de plus
pour ne pas se faire prendre les
papetières le ferais discrètement durant
la nuit comme le montre cette vidéo
amateur tournée en septembre
waouh kumar un fermier veut nous montrer
des preuves concrètes de cette
combustion illégale par les papetières
il nous emmène dans ses champs près des
usines ou des camions viennent décharger
les cendres rejetées par l'industrie et
au pied de ces montagnes grise des
restes calcinés de plastique
2 l'économie
les images de nos déchets en inde sont
choquantes et c'est aussi le cas vous
allez le découvrir en indonésie là-bas
la question du pourcentage de plastique
ou de contamination c'est pas une notion
théorique notre plastique ils le mangent
ils le boivent le respire
[Musique]
le biologiste de prix guy harrison 10,8
à surabaya dans l'est de l'île
indonésienne de java une région où se
concentrent beaucoup de papetières son
enquête commence en 2017 lorsque la
chine annonce le resserrement de ses
règles et qu'il voit soudainement
apparaître autour de lui de grandes
quantité de plastique étrangers
nous la question qu'on se pose est
pourquoi des papetières jette-t-elle
autant de plastique chez nous
il décide d'aller voir de plus près
on a fait voler des drones au dessus des
papetières
on est même allés dans les usa
[Musique]
j'ai aussi parlé aux gérants des usines
et m'ont dit oui depuis 2010 est il y à
beaucoup plus de plastique dans les
ballots de papier avant c'était moins de
10% mais depuis il y a de 30 à 40%
plastique et
[Musique]
c'est comme un cheval de troie on met du
plastique dans du papier parce que c'est
moins réglementées pour le papier
à cause de l'opacité à cause des flux
monumentaux de déchets donc de la quasi
impossibilité de contrôler l'ensemble
des exportations le commerce
international des déchets est une
spécialité de l'avocat david azoulay
on a évidemment une augmentation je
dirais presque automatique mathématiques
des taux de contamination ailleurs au
fur et à mesure que tous les acteurs
cherchent des moyens camoufler ou pas de
se débarrasser des quantités massives de
plastique qu'on produit
comme en inde près qu'ils découvrent que
le plastique de mauvaise qualité extrait
des ballots de papier et brûlé mais
cette fois ci comme combustible pour
fabriquer un produit familier le tofu
une pratique inquiétante en 2019 des
tests sur des oeufs poules ont
d'ailleurs révélé des niveaux dangereux
de produits chimiques tondez dioxine
il ya environ
40000 type d'additifs chimiques
particulier donc on sait qu'ils sont
utilisés dans l'industrie plastique
parmi ces quarante mille substance il y
en a plusieurs milliers voire plusieurs
dizaines de milliers qui sont
cancérigènes mutagènes perturbateurs
endocriniens et parmi les éléments qui
sont
créés quand on brûle du plastique à ciel
ouvert il ya des jokes ignorons les
dioxines c'est les substances les plus
cancérigènes que l'être humain a jamais
identifié
après ces découvertes reggae harrison
dit multiplient les actions pour alerter
les autorités sur l'importation de
papier contaminer les règles et les
contrôlent se resserre en indonésie ils
essaient aussi d'alerter les pays
occidentaux dans la capitale jakarta il
fait le tour des ambassades des
cinq banques l'odeur du sbc
puis dans l'île vis
à vis
de
samba khary qanater canada
trois ans plus tard il attend toujours
une réponse du canada
mais les pays comme le canada se sont
déjà tournés vers d'autres marchés plus
accommodant comme l'inde et là aussi des
citoyens s'inquiètent de l'impact de ce
commerce sur leur santé ainsi vous voyez
comme cette feuille change de couleur
habituellement elle est comme ça
ce sont des particules de cendres comme
ça qu'ils m'ont blessé aux yeux un
d'entre eux chez vous je pouvais rien vu
suite
[Musique]
mais un thomas est une championne
internationale de tir pour exceller ses
yeux sans ce qu'elle a de plus précieux
mais il y a deux ans elle a commencé à
avoir de sérieux problèmes la faute dit
elle des cendres rejetées par les
papetières
je vis dans le village de macally depuis
que je suis petit c'est une région
industrielle
et chaque année de nouvelles usines
s'ajoutent aux produits chimiques une
fois j'ai reçu beaucoup de cendres dans
les yeux et où la terre pendant deux ou
trois jours j'ai pas pu
le médecin m'a dit que j'avais 12 ou 13
coupures dans les yeux comme ceux comme
bad as été raconter
sur le terrain de l'école de tir une
poussière grise recouvre toutes les
surfaces
et sa mère et nous ont même milité lors
des dernières élections municipales au
freiner la pollution des usines
vous voyez nous sommes entourés du cndi
quatre côtés vous voyez toute cette
fumée on est comme dans un élevage et
c'est toujours comme ça et il ya le
bruit aussi on ne peut plus respirer
avec toute cette pollution
à quelques kilomètres de son terrain ce
canal au milieu des champs qui n'a rien
de bucolique et sur ses bords se trouve
le village de ban doha on nous dit ici
que les papetières sont aussi en grande
partie responsable de cette eau souillée
personne n'est
guère
plus près de lusine l'eau est presque
entièrement couverte d'une sorte de
croûtes indéfinissable
dans plusieurs villages autour des
usines on nous a parlé d'une hausse de
maladies de toutes sortes qui seraient
liées à la pollution hatch en cours raul
kumar et ses amis ont même commencé à
colliger les dossiers des cas de
problèmes respiratoires comme l'asthme
de maladies de la peau et de cancer
même les hommes plus âgés qui se tenait
jusqu'ici en retrait veulent témoigner
et une chance est clair pour tout le
monde ici la combustion du plastique
joue un rôle majeur dans ses problèmes
de santé nous avons vérifié au cours des
dernières années des papetières mais
aussi des fabricants de briques et de
sucre ont été condamnés à des amendes
pour avoir brûlé clandestinement du
plastique
le jour de notre arrivée nous avions
remarqué près d'un des dépôts de
plastique de la fumée noire s'échappant
d'un petit bâtiment on nous avait dit
que c'était un fabricant de jack gris un
sucre non raffiné très prisé ici
et que plusieurs de ces petites
entreprises utilisent le plastique comme
combustible
à côté du four il y en ait fait un tas
de bois et un plus petit de plastique
devant nous l'ouvrier ne brûlera
toutefois que le bois
pankaj agarwal et sa famille sont
propriétaires de plusieurs usines à
mozafar naggar malgré les preuves dont
nous lui avons parlé le président de
l'association des papetières de la
région nous assure que tout le plastique
récupéré est éliminé légalement par son
industrie oui
nous le donnons cimenterie 30 40 50 60
tonnes par mois oui bientôt
6000 plants d use it flow burning
sabrina de conditions environnementales
et v5 très pas de problème vous pensez
que les gens au canada devraient être
contents de voir comment ça se passe ici
alors les autorités font fausse route
parce que j'ai vu qu'elles ont imposé
plusieurs amendes en lien avec cette
combustion plastique
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire les
assurances de l'industrie ne
convainquent pas les habitants des
environs quatre chefs de village se sont
unis pour dénoncer auprès des autorités
la combustion des déchets de plastique
le gouvernement distille intervient de
temps en temps mais les usines
reprennent vite leurs mauvaises
habitudes pour l'avocat david azoulay la
crise chinoise a été une occasion ratée
de revoir le modèle inéquitable du
commerce mondial des déchets la réaction
naturelle de tous ces opérateurs
économiques ça a été de trouver un moyen
pour que leurs
business models comme on dit puis ce
qu'il puisse continuer et donc c'était
d'abord de trouver des destinations
alternatives en asie
le jour de notre départ l'épisode de
smoke toxiques comment cet appel à
s'atténuer l'inde est l'une des régions
monde les plus affectés par la pollution
de l'air pourquoi des pays comme le
canada
doivent-ils en rajouter demanderez nous
et raul à madaillan
population augmente et la pollution ne
cesse de s'aggraver
par dessus le marché on permet au canada
et à d'autres pays d'envoyer leurs
déchets dans nos villages ce qui
augmente encore plus la pollution
notre gouvernement devrait faire quelque
chose
vous avez vu mon petit village et ses
environs vous avez vu quoi ça a l'air
le plastique vient des pays comme le
vôtre mais c'est nous qui avons tous les
problèmes
[Musique]
dans le dossier du recyclage tout le
monde se renvoie la balle la ville la
province les entreprises les courtiers
mais ce qu'on doit retenir en bout de
ligne si qu'au canada il ya très peu de
contrôle sur les déchets qu'on envoie
polluer ailleurs sur la planète est-ce
qu'on se ferme les yeux pour se donner
bonne conscience qu'il ne fait pas bon
et juste devant
l'atelier d'aujourd'hui va vous forcer à
regarder plein matériaux ou alors des
techniciens nous rassembler pour tous
les matériaux dans les bacs titan
mélange
au cégep de sorel tracy marc ollivier
forme de futurs techniciens en
environnement hygiène et sécurité
au programme aujourd'hui le recyclage
des gens se servent souvent un bac avec
eux en mettant plein de trucs long
document borloo
mais vous allez devenir des conseillers
[Musique]
nous lui avons montré des images de tous
les déchets canadien découvert en aide
il venait de blesser que plein de trucs
qu'on reconnaît ce sont nos propres
emballages ces canadiens ces québécois
effectivement si on a pris la peine de
le trier c'est qu'on voudrait que ce
soit risqué mais visiblement ce qu'ils
ont reçue lors c'est quelque chose
tellement piètre qualité que c'est
désespérant entachent la réputation du
canada expédiées à l'étranger des balles
ou qui sont comme ça la ville de
montréal défend ricco va en disant
qu'elle n'a pris possession du centre de
saint michel qu'en 2020 comment
expliquer qu'on soit si loin nos
objectifs le centre saint michel on sait
qu'il ya des défis technologiques se
concentre plus vieux
mais y est censé y est prévu des
améliorations pour améliorer la qualité
du tri et on le valide chaque mois on
maintient la pression pour que la
qualité augmente les acquisitions ont
été faites les les appareils ont été
reçus donc à compter de janvier 22 on
s'attend à une amélioration
nous réalisons que les autorités de la
ville ne sont pas au courant renvoyer
des balles aux contaminés à 25% en inde
c'est illégal et si vous me dites que en
vertu des règles intérieures de ligne
c'est ballot là n'aurait pas dû entrer
mais là on tombe dans une autre
compétence qui est celle de la ville on
est dans les règles du commerce
international
de toute façon nous dit la responsable
de l'environnement
la ville n'a pas de prise légalement sur
l'exportation des matières recyclables
on a une clause en notre contrat qui dit
à prix égal on favorise le marché local
mais si le marché de l'export offre un
prix plus élevé pour les ballons ils
vont être vendus à l'export on devrait
être capable de démontrer citoyens que
l'effort qu'il fait c'est pour créer de
la valeur ajoutée sur son territoire pas
à l'écrire les cônes l'activité
économique en thaïlande ou bien au
vietnam où viendra en aide mais non en
chine c'est sur le territoire qu'il faut
qu'on fait c'est comme si le ya eu une
lome dégradation on a perdu de vue
pourquoi on demande aux gens de
récupérer des matières is the cette
tension entre les lois du libre marché
et le voeu pieux environnementaux et les
constantes elle pourrait peut-être se
résoudre si quelqu'un vérifier ce qui
arrive à nos matières en bout de ligne
mais ce n'est pas le cas ni au niveau
provincial ni à la ville de montréal et
une fois que le produit est vendu
la ville de montréal peut pas suivre la
trace comme tel on s'est vraiment au
dessus de nos moyens nous
contractuellement au fait tout ce qu'on
peut dans la mesure de nos pouvoirs
après il ya aussi une responsabilité
morale des entreprises
selon la ville c'est donc sur les
épaules d'entrepreneurs comme dominique
couloubrier aller que repose une partie
de la responsabilité
selon les données import export que nous
avons obtenu 500 mille tonnes de papier
mixte canadiens ont été exportés entre
2019 et 2021 en inde
et la moitié l'a été par ricoh va
le président de ricoh va dit qu'il ne
peut pas contrôler ce qui se passe en
inde quand on est allé en inde on est
allé dans les sur les terrains autour
des usines tous les rejets de sacs de
plastique qui venait des ballots
sérieusement c'était tout des marques
québécoises canadiennes presque toutes
les règlements sont possibles comme ici
ça se peut que tu sais les gens au fait
de décocher un peu partout est ce que
vous êtes déjà allé voir en elle qu'est
ce qui arrivait avec un petit coup de
fouet oui mais c'est pour un club au
plus près de lui je pense que toutes les
industries 1 c'est pas moi je peux le
dire cela
ici on n'est plus tout seul et on a plus
de règlement c'est plus la carlingue on
n'a pas une responsabilité
envoyer les produits comme ça si on sait
qu'au bout de la ligne on va parce que
on fait des affaires et btg que ça fait
longtemps que je pense qu'ils sont
responsables
comme ça je me dis des appartements mais
quand même on fait des affaires avec des
jacks ce sont des business par dizaines
d années
comme le représentant des papetières en
inde il dit que si du plastique et brûlé
s'est fait de façon légale
je sais qu'il ya une partie qui brûle
mais je sais pas si monsieur social mais
ça c'est le qu'est-ce qui brûlent
sénégal parce que ces poulets cimentière
le plastique est brûlé dans des
conditions plus contrôlés dans des
cimenteries mais ça reste une pratique
controversée
et nous avons aussi recueilli tous ces
témoignages en inde de travailleurs et
de villageois sur des façons plus
dangereuse de se débarrasser d'une
partie du plastique dans plusieurs
industries
devant les résultats de notre enquête le
ministre fédéral de l'environnement
reconnaît que l'exportation de déchets
canadien très contaminés n'est pas
acceptable que ce soit pour la pollution
plastique pour toute forme de pollution
d'exporter sa d'exporter ce dans un pays
encore plus un pays en voie
développement c'est inacceptable il faut
travailler à éliminer ça pour diminuer
la dépendance envers les marchés
étrangers les gouvernements fédéral et
provincial mise en grande partie sur la
réduction à la source du plastique mais
les réformes ne seront pas en place
avant plusieurs années
en attendant marc de strooper va tenter
d'enrayer le flot de déchets salle même
si non stop qu'une infime partie depuis
notre voyage en octobre dernier il a
saisi quatre autres expéditions
contaminée en provenance de différentes
provinces canadiennes
cela me fait mal au coeur mais
ce que je peux faire c'est renvoyé vers
le canada mais si le passé est garant de
l'avenir les compagnies impliquées s'en
sortir facilement depuis 2016 123
conteneurs de déchets plastiques rebut
ou papier on était retourné au canada
par six pays la sanction c'est ce lettre
d'avertissement le ministère de
l'environnement fédéral refuse de
dévoiler à qui elles ont été envoyées je
pense qu'effectivement au niveau de la
surveillance et des conséquences pour
les entreprises on doit on doit
améliorer le système au canada et aucun
doute là dessus
j'ose espérer que ce qu'on voit l'eau
vont concerner un petit pourcentage
ce qu'on appelle les mines et matières
et gary
finalement par rapport à un ensemble où
on réussit à faire beaucoup mieux ce qui
est important c'est que même si on
constate que des choses qui sont posées
aux jo il faut pas que ça décourage nos
gens ici de d'essayer de bien faire
on
[Musique]